just as I predicted a few weeks ago a
brand new search engine for developers
has emerged if you ask chat EBT to write
you a tutorial with the latest next JS
version that dropped last week it'll
fail because of its training cutoff but
this tool can get the job done perfectly
because it pools all the latest
documentation from the web while citing
its sources and you can tailor it to
give you a long-winded expert tutorial
where it can size to the point answer
it's basically your own programming
tutor and that's not good news for me so
if you guys know of any coal mines that
might be hiring right now please let me
know